what is your favorite NBA play of all
time definitely when Ray Allen hit the
corner three I think it was game six
bang shot any reality hit that that 43
daytime moment really good shooter I
remember watching that as a kid that's
when I always remember the Ray Allen
Corner three that was pretty pretty
tight definitely apologize Birdman Vince
Carter jumping over the dude for USA AI
when he stepped over Hyrule game seven
black jerseys with that Cav logo on
LeBron had blocked on Andre Iguodala
they get to steal they go down and King
James comes behind and beats them
Absolute crap out of the ball the
sequence of it and then the commentators
going crazy is like get your Goosebumps
on my flight that's just a legendary
moment Luca dances stuck in the corner
in there and he had like multiple
Defenders on him or something I don't
know how he made the pass but it was
like an unreal pass I seen it I was like
wow like that was actually crazy